there's a lot of there's a lot of what
good memes this man it's so that's a
nice batch of me mrs. Swede you see the
one of the two girls rapping in the car
yeah I watch that I watched it fringed
my teeth out can we play it can I play
it just Mike just hit like if you just
get the gist I mean wait okay I know I
feel like I can say what to white girls
rapping in a car to their iPhone I feel
like everyone knows exactly how this is
gonna sound no because because those
videos got popular because they were
good okay this style like those two
girls I don't
Ashley in whatever I don't know they
were pretty good I think their videos
kept going viral because it was actually
these they were like decent rappers okay
alright so I I wat like I when I first
saw the thumbnail for this video I was
like this video either way
yeah this has a [ __ ] ton of likes it's
either [ __ ] awful or it's so good
there's nothing in between
nah nah it ain't just gonna be average
alright it's already bad yeah yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna slide in gonna slide in gonna
have some fun yeah wait wait oh yeah oh
yeah girl on left comes in just still
the girl on the right yeah
my fellow hit me up okay right it's just
kid she's about to go into get already
take off on it get ready guys all right
Kip tell blue face to chill out so tell
blue face to chill the [ __ ] out she's
faced with the two times snapchat
filters yeah yeah yeah that's double
speed blue face right but she started
taking off on that [ __ ] anyone with less
rhythm in my whole life funny she's a no
concept of like beep y'all people want
to just talk about how I'm single and I
just can't believe that and sound like
complaining bro saying [ __ ] that's not
like somebody's trying to get through
their [ __ ] high school presentation
Jam through it you wanna be out there
and I just like I just like to say these
people switching up like Smeagol thank
you very nice
it's perfect yeah yeah perfectly shitty
because these girls like they're they're
doing the hand motions and [ __ ] to their
like uh-huh make a my fella uh-huh
eyebrows on fleek blah blah blah speed
rapping sphere every verses yeah in one
verse yeah she killed that [ __ ] bro oh
there we go sup dude
what is this yeah well I gotta call you
back in like 20 minutes
who's that let's Colby
oh all right
I love the Oh hard atoms you remind me
of a [ __ ] bored of would you remind
me of a two-by-four cuz you're [ __ ]
cuz you're rock-solid cuz you're thick
you got thick wood I don't understand
the disk there I don't know what's goin
on
that mean that's how good it is yes WAP
here you're an idiot yeah
and that's not even the only a song meme
this week Lance Stewart on genius did
you see that I've not heard the song and
I didn't watch the genius genius is
[ __ ] cold dude yeah they bring those
people on just the cars to have them
made yeah just a clown man yeah just
have make fun of themselves they be
alright they'd be like yeah yeah yeah so
what was you thinking on that first line
yeah sing it
why are you just sing it ya know ever
that's what it is it's like an a
cappella things just like perform a
little bit you should simply [ __ ] yeah
so what's up show me pipes this is what
all your pipes they started it with that
okay they probably asked them hey how
long you been singing for okay cuz
you're pretty good man how long you been
doing it oh just a couple years you're
really good for a couple years
please why do you sing something why you
sing something for us oh yeah damn yeah
I don't know man I was like yellow cards
slap right there a little bit yellow
card slap right there you heard that
damn song
no that's doesn't follow boy mm-hmm
isn't it oh no that's panic at the
Disco's yeah whatever man they're all
the same to me they'll all in pop punk
[ __ ] they be me you hitting
them notes if they if we ever go in
genius for anything we got a full-on
full-on sing every verse everything even
if it's not something that ever song it
is yeah if it's just rapping we have to
sing it like a totem pole yes when I
wrote that she's she [ __ ] with my
farmer's tan E flat E flat 10 yes so
when he wrote that we was in a rice
field in Indonesia just thinking about
how different our lives were and as the
air hit my [ __ ] beautiful voluptuous
cheeks my dick was out yeah standing
their dick out looking over this rice
field my dick was flapping around from
the wind from the breeze and I'm like
damn my dick is is - Tom call it a
phantom rice so that's how I came up
with the line for drip and then Cody was
admiring his own two-tone and he was
like damn I did kind of farmer's tan
though mm-hmm and then you know I'm
saying from there it was just like it
became a movie you know we started
seeing how like the girls start they
don't really [ __ ] with the farmer's tan
and then he wrote the farmer's tan you
know I'm saying that's a bar that's a
bar right there and yeah the guy's like
no see we got a director what we got to
relate all this shit's of like deep
aspects of history
yeah like [ __ ] a touring shitty
boring [ __ ] [ __ ] dude she into
animals cuz she [ __ ] with the goat
yes on the 1400s the Ming Dynasty they
controlled like central China
and and and merchants were like
persecuted for like trying to move silk
because merchants see the mercy there's
a there was a other separate like like
Islamic community that lived in the
north and they were taken over by the
Ming Dynasty so they were only allowed
merchants jobs and the silk was actually
horses removed from Turkey and so yeah
so like so pretend so goats goats were a
key move and just keep turning the silk
you know what I think we got a little
Uzi vert coming in so you guys got I
[Laughter]
haven't fully explained the bar yet just
crazy crazy information some [ __ ] is is
a it's just like a factoid like like
some like Twitter account [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] smoking on his G fuel that's some G
[ __ ] yes so 80% of people commit crime
are between the ages of 13 22 I got that
from a Snapple lid what I'm sipping ggb
[ __ ] yeah you know like termites yeah
termites they they they only have a
lifespan of like six years oh oh and if
they ever got from me they put us on
that [ __ ] we're gonna [ __ ] with him so
bad dude you get to one bar you like I
stole that that's on mine
yeah I took that [ __ ] that from someone
else who was it's like who him he did it
he did he took my [ __ ] yeah my [ __ ] so
word okay yeah that was mine yeah he
took it
did you want it back nope no no no
that's cool hehe had it or one of the
bars we just breathe yeah yeah or just
or just we just say the line as the
meaning I know the owner Paul he let me
drink for free I know the owner was
names Paul and home he just lets me
drink for free that's pretty dumb
Paul's a nice guy he's a nice guy shut
up Paul [ __ ] dude it's not funny if we
do it ourselves like they have to bring
us on and we gotta [ __ ] with oh no I
just like totally bring it home goddamn
it well that's what you guys have to
look forward to if we if we ever get on
genius you
you